[Music]
hulu is putting together a holiday
surprise for two
fans of their latest original film
happiest season
here we are decorating the house getting
ready for austin nina's arrival
tonight asta is planning to propose to
nina
nina has no idea she thinks asta's
bringing her to a company holiday party
we have hidden cameras going up we're
all pretending to be the catering staff
this is gonna be awesome
they've just arrived welcome to the
party party i'm so excited
we do have the place to ourselves for a
little bit maybe we should dance
oh my god this view the cover story is
working for now as
nina gets wrapped up into their romantic
location
can i just tell you yeah fortunate i am
to have you in my life
oh this is the perfect moment for asta
to propose
the ring is hidden in nina's favorite
noodle dish all right guys we have some
vegan noodles right here
what oh my god
wait i love it so much and
thank you so much for fighting for us
from the very beginning and thank you
for making me laugh until my cheeks hurt
and i want that feeling for the rest of
my life and i would love the honor
to be my wife so i have to ask you dear
will you marry me
yeah she said yes
[Music]
oh my god this is not a holiday party
oh my god congratulations
this was in partnership with hulu in
support of their new film
happiest season this is a dream
i had no idea this was gonna happen this
was a complete surprise
i had a co-worker who had a friend at
the knot and they're doing this cool
thing with hulu
and they're looking for someone to
propose and i was planning on proposing
like early next year but i was like this
is perfect because me and my lesbian
friends have been looking forward to
this movie
for months now and so i wanted this day
to come faster
i'm really lucky that you're mine and oh
my god i'm so teasing right now
we love holiday rom comes we definitely
see happiest season becoming our like
yearly movie that we watch
having representation matters and i
think sharing love stories of lgbtq plus
folks something that's really important
to us we're so excited to watch
original film happiest season before the
movie begins
hulu and happiest season have one more
surprise in store for nina and asta
i'm cleo duvall the director and
co-writer of happiest season
and i just wanted to say congratulations
to asta and nina on your engagement
oh my god congratulations you guys
you're getting married
congratulations nina and asta hey dan
levy here
um just heard the exciting news
congratulations
it's so exciting congratulations
wishing you both a lifetime of happiness
congratulations
on this great day mr garber i hope you
have the loveliest life together
that was so good thank you hulu and
happiest season
happiest season now streaming only on
hulu
you